what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday september the 6th
the joint is brought to you from the
heart of new jersey by draftkings listen
to me
football season has arrived [__]
the first sunday of the nfl is finally
here
sunday september the 12th you got the
jags at the texans you got the charges
at washington the seahawks at the colts
it's the best
[__] time of the year listen i am
[__] ecstatic
we'll be watching sundays every sunday
i'll have draftkings in my pocket
download on the [__] phone because
draftkings is the official
sports betting partner of the nfl giving
all new players a hell of a [__]
offer
all right let me tell you something
draft bet one dollar on any nfl game
this season and cash 200 bucks and free
bets no matter what you heard me right
free [__] money draftkings is the
best in the west it's safe secure and
reliable so download the draftking
sportsbook app now use promo code joey
to receive
200 and free bets when you place a
dollar bet on any week one game it's
that easy for a limited time only at
draftkings sportsbook app download it
right [__] it now
you got to be 21 older new jersey
indiana pennsylvania only new customers
only
restrictions do apply but draftkings.com
sportsbook see them for details now
if you got a gamer problem you got to
call 1-800 gambler if you're in indiana
1-809 with it if you don't have a
problem
download the draftking sportsbook app
and let's win some [__] guitars you
can't get into any problems in
draftkings because you gotta pay as you
bet this is not betting over your head
this is more fun [__] so download
the draftking sportsbook app
the joint is also brought to you by
c
b
d lion
from the cbd capsules the broad spectrum
to the vegan cbd gummies to the cbd
cream to the extra smooth i mean listen
the basketballs the hemp flower
i can't talk
i can't even tell you all the great
things about cbd line what you need to
do is go to cbdline.com
read the third party lab results and ask
yourself do i need this in my life
i got a knee that bothers me i got some
anxiety i have some problems sleeping
these gummy bears will put you out they
got melatonin in that tremendous but do
me a favor
the balls in your court go to
cbdlinewrite.com right now
read read cbn cbd cby
make your order they'll recommend what
you need
put in code joey
joint
church and get 20 off
delivered to your [__] crib you
understand me
it's that easy
cbd lion will put it together for you
every time
so go to cbdline.com right now
look at the fine selection of cbd
products like i said to you from the
back wall to the cream
pressing code joey
and the world is your oyster you
understand me
cbd line code joey get 20 off delivered
right to your house let's get this party
started right now
the joint monday morning
[Music]
welcome to uncle joey's joy
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday september the 5th
just sounds [__] good saying
september the 5th like i told you in the
beginning of the sixth oh [__]
one two three
wow
the sixth already holy [__] this is what
i'm [__] talking about it just feels
good it just [__] feels good the
first week of september i know about you
guys
it just feels great happy labor day i
know a lot of years of [__] uh
planning on barbecuing and seeing your
buds this afternoon
and whatever it's great i'm doing the
same [__] thing so don't feel bad i
had a great weekend i'm doing a lot a
lot a lot [__] better as you can tell
by looking at me and uh how i'm talking
it's been
quite a [__] ride
but uh the weeks are getting easier i uh
took my daughter to see the [__] ten
rings of chin chow on [__] saturday
tremendous movie [__] yeah let me tell
you something all those disney movies
are a lot better than anything you'll
[__] see on your own i i
i am just convinced they they
you know from despicable me to [__]
all those movies you sit there
with your kids if you have kids i don't
know i'm talking to young people or old
people i don't give a [__]
but if you sit there you know you're
like oh this is going to suck and then
you start paying attention and watching
and you're like
you know what this isn't bad and they're
playing good music what pixar did was
start playing good music to get the
parents involved
so now my daughter is sitting in a
[__] car we'll be driving we'll
listen to 70s on seven on sirius and
she'll hear i i'm still standing by
elton john and she's like dad it's elton
john so it's [__] tremendous they get
to learn a little bit but i've been to
movies like regular movies they just
suck
disney and marvel put so much into their
[__] movies like especially disney
pixar it was just great my daughter
drank a [__] whole thing of slushy
first off the movies in jersey are
[__] rip off
listen i'm not a cheap person by no
means
but when i pay 701 for a bottle of
[__] water let me tell you something
i drank that [__] water all the way
to the end i melted it i snorted it i
[__] [__] it out and then i got a
nickel back for the [__] bottle
you're seven dollars i'm drinking every
drop of that [__] water
for i when i got water
a popcorn for my daughter i hate [__]
popcorn and the [__] smell of it and
i'll eat it though if it's buttery and
i'm stoned to the gills but i wasn't
stoned and whatever so
i [__] uh
got a popcorn a slushie and a water
and it was 23
and i [__] could not believe it and
then i went back for a hot dog and it
was seven dollars and i was like
what the [__] is this [__] and you don't
say nothing you were your kid you know
you don't even think about it till you
get in the car trust me i didn't even
think about it in the car i thought
about it as i was giving her the seven
dollars
that this [__] hot dog better be that
good do you guys remember when vinnie i
don't know if you remember there was
this guy vinnie curtis a boxer great guy
he did uh
he did uh beauty and the beast
[__] great episode and then he did
the church once or twice great episodes
always a tearjerker the guy's [__]
got a uh
he's just a [__]
knowledge he's just a fountain of
knowledge vinnie curto he's a boxer he's
a great guy i haven't spoken to him in
like four years he disappeared i called
the number but vinnie used to have a
story
about [__] sinatra if you get sinatra
live at caesar's palace vinnie curtis
spread all over the [__] album he's
in there pictures of him the whole thing
and he has a story that he went to
sinatra's in palm springs
at uh one day and he's sitting there and
that sinatra came out of the room hung
over and he's like you know what i'm
gonna move for a hot dog you're in the
mood for a hot dog vinny i'm in the mood
for a hot dog he called the pilot he
goes do me a favor go to vegas and pick
up some hot dogs and come back
the [__] plane trip was like three
thousand dollars
and the hot dogs were maybe like
fourteen dollars you know it was more
for the trip to vegas
than the hot dogs right so vinnie crudo
said when the hot dogs came back he was
poor you know he was impressed that
sinatra got [__] hot dogs from las
vegas
and got him flown back and he goes he
ate every [__] single hot dog because
he clocked them at like a hundred
dollars a piece
so he just kept eating them he goes
these are the best [__] hot dogs i've
ever eaten in my life 100 hours a piece
and that's the same way i feel about
this water it's this [__] water it's
a dasani water they charge me seven
dollars for i brought that [__]
home you know how you usually throw away
a water when it's got two inches in it
this [__] i'm drinking every
[__] lick of this [__] thing
so that was great you know going to the
movies but
i'm a movie guy i don't know if you guys
know this or whatever i grew up
a movie guy it is a shame
what's going on in this country today
with theaters it's a shame i told my
wife yesterday i go you know what
i have a new mission in life i think i
want to open up a [__] small theater
like a small that theater in newark
there's a theater in newark that's old
and ratty
you open that up you clean the rats out
of there you take some of the sperm off
the [__] floor
you put a nice carpet in there you make
nice brownies
with [__] walnuts in them you make a
nice
popcorn with fresh butter not that
[__] liquid [__] [__] they give
you at the movie theater
and you just have like chocolate chip
cookies and a made every 30 minutes even
if they're [__] popping fresh dough
you know the ones you chop just
something nice at a movie theater and
just you know let the people know listen
man i got nice stuff here
i'm gonna put couches some couches
some foot rest up some nice chairs
you know i'm gonna charge you 20 but
it's going to be an experience like any
[__] other
you know that's what i'm thinking of
doing but i know i'm going to get raped
you know
the [__] i heard that when you
uh show a movie you don't make a dime
you don't make a dime on the movie you
have to everything you make on that
movie you have to pay you make your
money on the popcorn and the seven
dollar [__] waters
and the [__] you know the whole thing
so i i get it part of it but no i don't
get part of it
why the [__] should i pay seven bucks
for a [__] movie
paid top dollar for the [__] you got to
give me a breather somewhere my wife
when i came home she's like well you're
part of the [__] amc club who gives a
[__]
it's still [__] 650 for a [__] hot
dog that just unheard of
and then today some guy told me uh
sunday i went to a football game
and some [__] guy told me because nah
that's why i sneak my own [__] into the
[__] movie theater waters raisinets
goobers
the whole [__] thing because if not
you get raped in there but you know you
feel cheap you feel like you're robbing
from somebody
it's not what i'm into doing but what
are you gonna [__] do but i think the
highlight of my weekend i went to a
football game a kids football game it
started raining it was great
i think the highlight of my weekend
was last week i was watching something
on showtime
and
they said that they were coming out with
a rick james documentary
and i was [__] excited i don't know
if you guys know this i love rick james
love them love them i've seen over 100
concerts
okay i've seen some phenomenal
technical concerts like people doing
their job
like pink floyd judas priest was always
tremendous harold smith was always
shitty uh you know ted nugent was always
great pat benatar put on a good show but
then i went to see shows that were buck
wild
what do i mean by buck wild
that they didn't give a [__] and the two
bands that i have to tell you that i
went to see one was the b52s on new
year's eve i think everybody was on
[__] quaaludes
and the second one was rick james in
84 in buffalo
i never saw anything like that in my
life i never saw anything like that in
my life i got like a side invite from a
friend of mine that i wasn't really
tight with i knew he was from buffalo
and i knew he was a rick james dude a
white dude
and he had told me an aspen about rick
james and how crazy the shows were
people sucking dick and women flying
through the [__] air and you know and
i was like come on man he goes no it's
it's
the craziest thing you see [__] pills
flying everywhere
reefer it was [__] insane
it was at a bar like a
i don't know if it was a venue i
shouldn't say a bar it was a venue
and you know i went i had the grammar
blow in my pocket for later i never did
coke at a concert
i had it for later i had a few [__]
uh quaaludes with me and i went up to
this [__] buffalo i uh flew up there
out of newark
my buddy picked me up we went to his
house we showered
and then we went to the show with
another girl and i got to tell you
[__] rich it was three hours
i was wiped when i left there you ever
go to a concert you're [__] tired
like thank god that [__] finish
jesus christ i'm high i hear [__]
trumpets in my ear
my legs are sore i got sweat [__]
everywhere i had sweat and every orifice
madonna was there madonna was somewhere
around there [__] people were saying
madonna was there i mean rick james put
on a hell of a [__] show
so when i heard the documentary was
coming i'm like i'll keep my eyes open
friday night i'm [__] around with the
girls we're playing games whatever i
come downstairs
and i threw the tv on and the
documentary had just started maybe 30
minutes in
and i was so [__] happy was a
two-hour documentary it's on showtime
[__] tremendous you know
there's a lot of people that i like as
musicians
and there's a lot of people i respect as
musicians do you know what i'm saying
like they've done something to make me
go
what the [__] was that you know
rick james was all those things i don't
know why
i think i had like three of his albums
uh you know street songs [__] uh
the one with cold-blooded i think it's
cold-blooded it's not that good as
street songs
and then i had another album i
definitely had the temptation song he
put out he was he produced on it uh
standing on the top
it was just he he's just a [__] mess
you know me dog i love messes and i
related to messes you know i found out
watching the documentary his mother was
a bookmaker
i found out he was a draft dodger i
didn't i didn't know about this [__]
it's tremendous he was a draft dodger
and he went to toronto and he ended up
being in a band with neil young
[__] the stories were tremendous he
got into a fight one night with these
rockers and the rockers that stuck up
for him with this band that he
found out it was [__] uh
robbie robertson and and and
the guy that just got accused of rape
and all that [__] uh that he molested a
girl uh
bob dylan it was dumb guys it was that
band it was the band that stuck up for
him he was hanging out with the band he
was hanging out with mick taylor from
the stones he was hanging out with
[__] i mean he was of the real deal
with crosby stills nash and young
he knew young i mean this is [__] and
you know when you
when you see something like that about a
person you're like oh this guy's just
not a [__] there's more behind the
bandana you know what i'm saying like he
explains that he was on a plane one time
and he saw an african woman with her
hair and he went up to her and he goes
what's that and she showed him pictures
and that's we got his hairstyle from
that's where he got that [__] jerry
curl from
i mean he you know it's just
it reminded me of songs he had i forgot
that he had a song about the police
way before
ice cube and nwa i mean rick james
was the real [__] deal i was sad that
i only got to see him one time but it
gets better
then when i started comedy rick james in
was when he [__] uh
burnt the chick with the crack pipe and
i remember i was an open mica and i was
grasping for straws
i was grasping for [__] material i
didn't know how what to write when i
read the rick james incident rick james
and his girlfriend
najaki whatever her [__] name is some
arabian chick
they [__] were out partying in
hollywood one night snorting coke they
would bring home chicks and they would
you know bust them out
[__] the chick would bust their
[__] and then rick james would close
the deal and [__] her up for sure rick
james would tape them having sex and
eating each other out rick james is a
super freak that's why this song worked
so that's why it worked you know you
can't sell something if you're not that
person you know what i'm saying so
uh he [__] uh invited a girl over and
they got all [__] and coked up they
were smoking crack
and supposedly this is the story i got
before the documentary
that he tied her up and burned it with
the crack pipe the documentary goes more
into it and explains that the girl rob
coke like when [__] shotgun dug
remember the shotgun doug story when he
[__] went into the room and he came
back and he took the chick robbed him so
he put a gun through her head same
[__] deal cocaine
is a [__] up drug
uh you know
so rick james tied her up
and was burning with a crack pipe so
that was what he did so i wrote a joke i
was an open mic you guys you can't
[__] be mad at me for this at least i
got the balls to tell you how bad the
joke was
my joke was that who was the first black
superhero it was
rick james
you know put down the gun [__] or i'll
burn you with my crack pipe it was the
dumbest [__] thing to come out of my
lips but it worked for the time being
who gives a [__] but i love rick james
you know he went to jail whatever i
always loved his music i loved the
[__] let me tell you something
when he would sing that song mary jane
the whole place would spark up
and this ain't 2010 this ain't 2020 when
wheat is legal they have wheat stores
this was when weed was totally illegal
the whole place was sparking up out of
[__] at the [__] uh
venue so
i had never seen anything like that yeah
i went to see rock bands where a couple
kids would smoke pot and pass to join
around
you go see [__] rick james
and that [__] was sparking up a
number it was tremendous it was one of
the best nights of my life
if i got to go back to the best concerts
like i said it was uh
definitely rick i never met him i wanted
to meet him he was in jail
and sure enough one night i'm at the
[__] comedy store
and i walk out to the front it's a
boring night and who's there talking to
the doorman
but [__] rick james
so you know me dog i'm not a [__]
[__] like that or anything i went back
inside
i had a long talk with myself
i said what do i do here i love this
[__] guy so i actually went up to
chewie that was the door guy's name who
was outside with him
and i go chewie i i hate to [__]
bring this on you man
can you introduce me to rick james i'm a
big fan of his
you know i go back to 78 with the
[__] you know because he busted
out in 81 rick james with street songs
with super freak and the other jam and
the other jam
but
in 78 when i went to five star
basketball camp and i was up there with
some brothers
they were already playing rick james
they were playing a song called you and
i
jesus [__] christ
it was one of my favorite [__] songs
of that summer you know my friends were
all into rock music and here i show up
with rick james like what the [__]
you're into the [__] yams yeah man i
love soul i loved earth winning fire at
that time i loved the eisley brothers i
loved all that [__]
but rick james when i was in the eighth
grade already i already knew where rick
james was i had bought that album that
you and i is on i forget the name of it
i'm very sorry you know he can't
remember [__] everything
but i i just love rick james so when i
saw
him at the store
sure enough i went up to chewy like a
gentleman and i go you know i don't want
to [__] up your i don't want to blow up
your spot as a young kid say
but
i want to meet him do you think it's
okay and i didn't get a picture i didn't
ask him for no [__] picture i just
went up to him and put my hand out
what's up buffy you know what i'm saying
that's that's what people from buffalo
new york call each other you know so i
said what's up buffy what's going on
nice to meet you we started talking i
told him i went to see him in 84. he
told me the name of the venue
i forgot now you know he was very nice
he was sober
and that was it i went on stage and i
mind my own business what do you think
he invited me back to his house to do
coke i'm never that [__] lucky you
know that nobody wants to do coke with
me and i probably didn't want to do coke
with him but it was uh
if you get a chance to watch the rick
james documentary
if you're into that [__] then uh
i suggest you give it a [__] spin it
was great
i enjoyed it you know and uh
it's just [__] up when you're a fan of
somebody and you have
sort of like the same flaws they had you
know it makes you
relatable like i i still remember like
looking up to rick james you know
and i don't want you guys to think that
just because he did coke i was a fan of
his my other biggest influence at that
time was a guy named michael corin a
basketball player he's an announcer for
the nets now he's never been in trouble
that guy like that guy's never been in
trouble and i hold him sacred as i did
when i was in the eighth grade to how i
do today as a matter of fact my friend
jim haye called me yesterday to ask me a
question and i got to call him back
today i'm going to ask him if he can
give me michael corrin's number and
maybe get him on the podcast this month
because i love [__] mike and now that
i'm in jersey he lives in jersey i live
in jersey so
what the [__] we might as well get
michael coren on here before we even
move any further
i know why you guys are watching this
today and we're going to talk about a
little bit
um
when i got the call on
saturday as of saturday day i wasn't
gonna talk about this on the podcast
because it's none of my business and
it's a [__] tragic [__] story
but it's in front of us uh saturday
night i started getting calls
that it was in t on tmz
and uh i read the article
and it broke my [__] heart uh she was
just on the podcast
last [__] wednesday and uh
i i don't know if you guys know
how much i love kate quigley i mean with
all faults and everything i mean we all
have faults
if you want to judge whatever um
i didn't realize until about two weeks
ago how good of friends we were you know
and what she meant to me
i had a lot of friends in la you guys
know that but
kate was a super friend with all her
faults with all her
nonsense with all her little [__]
craziness of [__] boys
and everything i i looked past that i
looked past that because
i always knew where kate's heart was
and that's very important for me i knew
where lee's heart was i knew what the
agostino's heart was
i knew what joe rogan's heart was i knew
where all these people's heart was you
know
um
so i turned the blind eye
when i love you
i turn the blind eye
and it's
it's not good
it's not good when i do that but i have
to do that
because i can never pull you aside and
go hey man you shouldn't be smoking pot
the amounts that you do hey man you
shouldn't be doing coke and the amount
you do hey man
you shouldn't be doing pills there's not
a lot of things i could pull you over
for
pull you aside for and say hey i'm your
friend i'm worried about you i think you
should give this a breather
it's never been
one of my uh
best traits that's not my best trait yes
i have taken people aside
that i care for and talk to them you
know if something
like now is the time to talk to kate
but before this i didn't see
it in my heart i had heard
say you know what you guys don't
understand is when i have a friend and i
hear stuff about them
sometimes i confront them
knowing them like if i really really
know them that well
but sometimes i can't confront them
because i know that don't ever talk to
me again
i had a dear friend who was on the
podcast maybe three or four times
i had heard some rumors around about him
one day i pulled him aside and i just
asked him a simple question i said hey
man
i heard some stuff
you know
take it easy with the nose candy
it's been about three years we haven't
smoked just from saying that to somebody
just because you can't you know
so i've learned my lesson the hard way i
knew
i know that i had dear friends that came
up to me when i was in my dilemma
getting high seven days a week and they
would pull me aside and say something
and it was a 50 50 whether i talked to
them again or not
you know something it's something about
people's addiction something about
people's problems
that unless they bring them up to you
you don't want to pull them aside and go
hey man
i heard you got high in pittsburgh
that's not has nothing to do with me and
i had
it happened to two people
and i think now i have a problem
i think now i have to change my
friendship ways because
i turned a blind eye to ralphie may
i heard all about the pills and all that
[__]
but i never questioned him on it because
i knew
if i questioned him on it
he wouldn't be my friend for much longer
some people are like that i don't know
why
i'm sure he wouldn't have talked to me
for like three or four months
and then we would have spoken again but
nothing would have been brought up so
that's why i didn't bring it up but
with uh
with kate i never brought it up we spoke
a couple weeks ago about it
she told me that you know she just gets
high here and there
so i didn't think it was really a
problem
when i got the call i was at a blues
jazz thing like a blues uh cookout
there was food trucks it was really cute
it was really [__]
set up great yesterday i took mercy to
the movies and then me and my wife
hooked up we hooked up with the
neighbors for a while we bullshitted
with them
and then at about uh
five we went over to this thing you know
my wife doesn't cook on saturday nights
i was like don't cook tonight
let's just [__] go out and uh
you know watch the game and i'll go to
the blues thing and
eat out there and then i took the girls
there first and while i was waiting
online for the barbecue
the phone rang it was uh ryan sickler
and i go ryan can i call you back and
he's like joey you have to hear this
he told me he just got the call that
two of the guys were with kate and uh
you know they did coke and she's in
critical condition and i just like
dropped the [__] brisket sandwich you
know
i got on the call i got on the phone to
wherever i could call and i uh
i made like 10 calls before i got to
anybody
and i finally got my mandi agostino
and uh he's dear friends of one of the
guys that passed
my heart goes out to the agostino
and rico's family in boston
you know hasn't been released yet
i'm telling you guys because i knew rico
he was a very sweet kid you know and uh
food the other kid that had died was
also
a very sweet kid i gotta be honest with
you
i know rico had demons but i didn't know
food did coke or anything like this this
is how listen guys i am so out of that i
am so
i am
26 000 degrees
from cocaine i don't know who does it i
don't know who doesn't do it you know i
heard at the store that there was a big
cocaine problem and this is between us i
i never saw it if you want me to [__]
when i was doing it yeah there was a
[__] problem i was snorting half the
[__] snowstorm i was half the [__]
blizzard i would go walk in the halls
and you hear
like a [__] blizzard yeah when i was
there that i was doing coke and i knew
the people were doing coke but once i
stopped doing it i'm so removed from
that world that i didn't even know what
the [__] was doing it
and when they told me that there was a
cocaine underworld
there at night
kate quigley's name never came up so i
was like okay we don't have a [__]
problem here you know once they start
talking about the comedy clubs that's
where it gets bad trust me i was one of
those people
that they started talking about you know
there was a couple club owners that
said little things about me and i wasn't
getting high at the club i was just
getting high in my room but
you could tell when you look when you
walk in to do a show at eight o'clock
and you look like you got hit by two
cars you know
they know that you're up to [__]
something so
i don't know what the [__] to say guys i
uh
i know you guys are looking to me
to
do a reaction on this i have no reaction
my heart goes out to her
like i told her agent who called me last
night i don't know i don't want them to
reach out to her mom
she mentioned it last week and uh she's
mentioned to me various times
that her mom's a little sick you know so
i don't want to push the mom over the
top
obviously you guys saw that she answered
back red band on twitter so uh red band
tweeted her and she uh
or text her
red band text a red band was one of the
concerned ones ryan sickler was very
concerned
diagonal was concerned lee was concerned
you know
the thing i didn't understand the most
about this
was whoever spoke to tmz
they threw hoodie on all this
you know why would you throw hoodie in
all this
i can't imagine what he must feel like
right now hoodie had nothing to do with
this
they hadn't been seen each other in
months why would you
mention hootie and then on the bottom of
the tmz article
it said that she was knee-deep in the
hollywood scene with jeff ross donnell
rawlings
myself and some other [__] names uh
what was that there for
to make me [__] feel bad to make
donnell feel bad i mean
what was that there for i i i didn't get
what that was there for it threw me for
a loop and i put a tear in my eye i was
like i hope people
don't associate me with [__] cocaine
i had no problems with it it's been 14
years since i even held that [__] in my
[__] hands so
i hope people and put me with this i'm
in [__] new jersey
for people who don't know
and this went down in california
so i have no [__] idea of what's what
guys
so before you even go there and start
saying joey
you're good friends i am dear friends
with her but
i have no [__] idea
you know what's going on i don't
talk to her on a weekly you know and
when i do talk to kate and i say to her
what'd you do last night
and she goes i did a spot at nova i did
a spot at the haha i don't ask if she
snorted coke last night that's got
nothing to [__] do with me you know
what i'm saying that's got nothing to do
with uncle joey i i
i'm saying prayers for her
i hope that uh
i hope that
she gets out of this okay i'm gonna call
an attorney uh
when i finish the podcast today
i'm gonna make a few calls tonight you
know once the holiday i don't think
[__] it's a holiday nobody's working
i'm gonna call an attorney and uh
just to see you know i have an attorney
friend here i'm gonna call
in a little while and just talk to him
and see
if she's gonna be in any trouble if she
needs an attorney
for uh you know when they sit down
around the cops i don't want to say
anything that's going to get her in
[__] trouble you know
and uh
that's the next step i'm going to just
talk to her when she's ready to talk to
me and no judgment
i'm gonna try to help her out as much as
i can you know i'm gonna try to
see if she wants to move back here with
us
for a month or two just to get a
family's love
and i'm gonna
turn around to better help that's the
the least you know that's the least i
could do real quick uh the joint is
brought to you today
by better help better help is uh is an
experienced
i i love better help i don't know
my life has changed
after a better help i never thought i
would be a
a student of therapy
but i was so [__] confused and the no
stand up and the [__] withdrawals and
the whole world had me twisted around if
you watch any of the podcasts in october
november
december january i just wasn't myself
and uh i reached out to a few free
people because i always believed that
your friends are the best best uh
therapy you could have
but i think i was a little wrong and
betterhelp.com really helped me out it's
affordable and you don't have to be
fancy ass new yorker
to pay for this financial aid is
available and now you can send messages
to your therapist anytime they'll get
back to you in between
sessions
okay it's all remote
you want to have
the [__] you'll never have to lay on
a stupid [__] couch again it's a
flexible schedule you could do it on the
phone on a video chat it's at your
convenience you can do it on zoom
and it's that they'll match you with a
perfect therapist for me it was one shot
dana dana
is tremendous she's helped me with the
comedy thing
she's helped me with the [__] pill
thing
she's helped me with some coping skills
i had problems with just you know
listen man we all have behavioral
problems we don't know how to [__]
act and i'm one of those people i'm not
scared to [__] admit it you know i'm
just one of those [__] people so
if you're having problems if you need to
talk to somebody this is very impersonal
you could do it right from the
comfort of your own home and guess what
take a look at me it [__] works i
love it i got a call with her tomorrow
uh at 5 30 with dana and
i got some stuff written down i run with
it
through her and that's my world now i
mean i'm 58 i've never gone through if i
knew what i knew now
i would have done therapy while i was
doing stand-up
last year 2019
2018 i really need to see a therapist
and better help fill the [__] void
for me so do me a favor
just for our listeners at the joint
betterhelp has a great offer to help you
get started okay what we're going to do
is this we're going to help you out with
betterhelp.com
diaz d-i-a-z
and i'm gonna give you 10 percent off
your first month first off it's
affordable it's cheap it's not going to
put you you know it's not going to set
you up it's not a car payment i love it
i love it because it's affordable it's
cheap i could do it in the morning i
could do in the afternoon i just come
back here throw the computer on boom it
gives you a link you have a password
onto your site she could send you
messages through there the scheduling is
through there it's nice and easy so do
me a favor go to betterhelp.com right
now sign up
press in codeas i'm going to give you 10
off your first month and you're going to
love it you're going to love it
go to betterhelp.com right now
press in code diaz and get 10 off your
first month
this is therapy
for 2021 no more going to an office and
sitting there and she's got a watch in
front of you you are getting sleepy i
don't want to do that either that's too
much drama for uncle joey betterhelp.com
if you want ask for dana she's done
wonders with me
you know i was stuck in some places i've
been stuck since i'm a kid you know me
so go to betterhelp.com
diaz so
as far as kate's concerned you know
i mean this is what
makes my [__] ears stand up
three people died
that's santeria type [__] like i gotta
go get a goat i can't even a chicken
won't even [__] help me i gotta get a
goat and like a lizard and offer them to
the [__] gods you know
three people passed away
three [__] people
you know and what i tell you guys in the
beginning all this [__] covert is about
[__] debt this whole period has been
about debt they've been negotiating for
our lives since last [__] march
this could never happen this could never
happen i've known 20 how many [__]
lines that i do
29 years of cocaine i never bumped into
[__] fentanyl
you know and now it's in everything guys
if you're in california
it's in everything i don't i don't know
if you guys know this i don't know if
you don't know this i don't know if you
want to hear this
you know i don't trust anything in
california listen thank god
thank god
i had a friend here in jersey who from
time when i would fly back to do comedy
shows he would wrap up two or three
xanaxes the blue ones and the aluminum
foil
and like i told mike they would last me
[__] two months
you know what i would get my xanax from
the doctor i would get all my blood
pressure medications from the doctor
i would get my weed from a legit place i
knew the grower i knew everybody because
i'm gonna tell you something
that [__] fentanyl isn't everything
in l.a
everything
if you buy mexicans xanax it's in there
if you buy mexican paint pills
it's in there you buy those [__]
pills they look like the ones that you
buy get them from the pharmacy but
they're not they're mexican they make
them in mexico and they throw a bunch of
[__] [__] in there you don't know
what the [__] you're taking how do i
know because about remember when i
pulled my [__] hamstring
november 18th whatever the [__] the date
was november 8th
when i pulled my hamstring that night
i'll never forget whitney coming saying
does anybody have a pain pill
and nobody had anything and people were
like what kind of comedy club is this
where there's no [__] opioids up in
this [__]
as i was walking out one of the young
girls that's a doorman
she was like a a phone girl or whatever
and sweet girl came up to me she goes
joey i went around all i could find for
you
was a little pain pill and a [__]
xanax
it was one of those blues annexes i bit
off half of one now my friend in jersey
had been giving me one and i would just
take on the road
you know if i had problems sleeping if i
got the j somewhere where there was a
time zone difference
i would have to pop one now
the one time i popped one from my that
night after the [__] that i pulled my
hamstring
the next morning i woke up i'm like um
something doesn't feel bueno i took that
pill what was left of it three quarters
i threw it in the [__] toilet it just
didn't feel good and i'm gonna tell you
something else there's [__] edibles
that got fentanyl in them
mike and i we're just talking about an
edible i used to get here that i've been
telling people for years
that this edible has some weirdness it's
those hashtags i used to get
listen uh you know more power to them
i'm not mad at them if they gave me one
now i'd probably take it that 30
milligrams but think about it
they were 30 [__] milligrams and they
would put you
on your [__] ass these things
i remember one day i did two or three of
them and i was falling asleep at a
restaurant and that was the night my
wife pulled me aside and she's like
listen joey you're 50 [__] seven
years old you can't be falling asleep at
a [__] restaurant at seven o'clock at
night and i'm like you got a point there
and that's when i stopped doing edibles
in the daytime it was because i was on
those [__]
hashtags and i was [__] nodding so
i've always said it the pharmacy years
ago i'm talking
15 years ago had a cookie that people
were getting [__] up on especially me
one night i ate a [__]
brownie from them and i had that
restless leg syndrome
from [__] la all the way to
pittsburgh on a connecting flight when i
was walking through a connecting flight
in chicago my legs were buckling on me
and [__] and i'm like i'll never eat
this [__] thing again i never did
and then
i kept saying you know what i'm gonna
give those pharmacy cookies and those
pharmacy brownies a little [__]
breather but what do you think happened
somebody [__] ate one of those
cookies
slipped banged their [__] head
they went down to the pharmacy bought a
cookie and had it tested and sure enough
that [__] had maluki juice in it
and like heroin so
you could feel when something's not
you could feel it guys
even with the [__] edibles i could
feel and i i swear to god i heard that
putting some fentanyl wheat
so you have to watch
what you get and what you they've been
putting fentanyl in the vaccine how's
that one for you [__] so if you
do a little [__] vaccine you're gonna
get a little fed and all doubt fentanyls
and everything you gotta assume
so do me a favor do your uncle joey a
big [__] favor
if you go to a party
if you're out
unless you know the [__] drug deal
and you've known him for years
and he's a reputable
drug dealer which
that's a [__] up oxy whatever oxymoron
a reputable drug dealer
there's no reputable drug dealers even
the [__] big farmer [__]
[__] tv [__]
and they're trying to [__] kill you
they really are big farmers a bunch of
tv [__] so when you say a reputable
drug dealer no i'm talking about like a
street dealer like if i was to do coke
which i'm not
after 14 years
there's only two people i would buy coke
from
two people that's it
if i was in jersey there'd probably be
three people i got a guy here that's
legit he's been doing it since [__]
the colombians you know opened up shop
and uh he knows where to get it do i
talk to him anymore no i haven't spoken
to him in three months but if i was to
do coke
that's where i would go to this guy
because he knows where to get the best
[__] powder in the world you know
what i'm saying so i don't know [__] i
don't know i know where to get weed
i know where to get great [__] wheat
speaking of wait great weed i hope you
stopped by [__] uh the ice cream shop
laughing gasses and full [__] effect
people hit me up on twitter going joey
i'm walking around feeling like kate
right now i smoke some of that laughing
gas
i'm [__] up you know what i'm saying
that laughing gas ain't no joke and this
ain't no joke these are little grand
bags
for biscotti
[__] tremendous reef that's a little
mikey
to get him going for a few days but back
to what we were talking about here
yeah i want you guys to i hope this is a
wake-up call for a lot of [__] people
and i hope this is a big wake-up call
for kate i love her this does not change
my admiration for her or my friendship
status with her and if you guys don't
like it i don't know what the [__] to
tell you go [__] yourselves you don't
abandon a [__] friend when she goes
through this right now
because i'll be honest with you i'm not
concerned about
the fentanyl
and the coke with kate i'm more
concerned with her insides
kate's got a great heart like i told you
[__] in the beginning
the most important thing the most
important gift that god gave me ever was
not comedy was not my [__] tolerance
to weed
was none of that
god gave me a gift to understand where
people's heart was
i just always when somebody gets in
trouble or whatever i know you want to
kick them in the [__] stomach
because that's what we're trained to do
as [__] douchebags
but i want you to step back and look at
the whole picture and go you know what i
know that person
i know that person world well i don't
know that person is like these people
know you know
so
i fell in love with kate
years ago because
she was just a simple little girl that
wants to be in love
that's it
that's it and she doesn't know where to
start
she's in a society that everybody's
pointed to your tits and your [__]
[__]
that's the society she's in
you know i've tried to talk her out of
that i tried to explain to her that
she's more
than just a pair of tits and [__] and a
pretty [__] face
she's a warm [__] woman man
and she's always been very warm to me
and there's comics that don't have her
warmth and she's been thrown under the
bus for years
female comics have always [__] on
[__] kate they've been rude to her
they've been mean to her and that's why
i was her friend all those years
because i you know i felt the same way a
lot of people didn't like me
for whatever reasons and you know what
they could suck my dick
because my heart's always been in the
right place if you meet me if you know
anything about me you'll say hey he's a
little [__] up
but his head's in the right place his
heart's in the right place at least he
[__] tries you know
and that's the most important thing so
when kate gets out of this she doesn't
need
help for her drug treatment or whatever
she's gonna need help in her heart this
whole
her relationship thing [__] her up you
know hey guys
you know throw a [__] rock if you've
never been [__] up over something
then you could cast a [__] stone but
until that time you can't
you know i don't know what the [__] is
happening in today's world that
everybody feels like they could you know
say [__] to you automatically it doesn't
work that way you know i was looking at
what happened last week
with rogan listen man
i spoke to rogan way before the [__]
where he got covert he was leaving for
florida on thursday i think i spoke to
him on like monday
we spoke about alternative treatments to
covet
we didn't speak about uh
the horse dewormer to be honest here but
we spoke about
monoclerio whatever the [__] you know
he's a smart dude he looked into all
this [__] you know if he didn't want to
get vaccinated he didn't want to give
back this people don't want to get
vaccinated i ain't [__] mad at you
but you know he got it on sunday he
really got it on thursday night because
it showed up on saturday night if you
read the [__] article or speak to him
he'll tell you
so sunday
monday tuesday wednesday thursday friday
that's five days the last time i [__]
checked
five not three he didn't test [__] he
didn't get clean in three days he went
where everybody else went through
five days some people go through ten
days he sped up the [__] thing like
he said he threw the [__] kitchen
sink at it
i mean listen
if you had the means and all this [__]
you would too
you know people are mad at him for doing
it people are mad at him for doing the
[__] wormer people are mad at him for
a thousand things he did it all right he
[__] quarantined he kept to himself
he didn't work out he didn't go out of
his way to [__] spread him he's
resting this week he's resting for a
couple days he's tired you know he was
just being honest
what he showed you
is what they're saying is [__]
what they say listen
i sat here with you guys and we talked
about vaccines you know listen i
wouldn't have gotten vaccinated but i
knew it was going to be this i got to go
to a [__] premiere this month i
wanted to go to the movies yesterday
with my uh saturday with my daughter
there's things i gotta do that they're
gonna ask for [__] vaccines i knew
this in the very beginning that's why i
went to get vaccinated i know if i
listen
people are getting it even though
they're vaccinated that don't sound good
and now they want you to run down and
get vaccinated something here don't
sound [__] right to me either but
it's too late i did it let's move the
[__] on and we're learning as we go on
you know you can order [__] uh the
trump [__] from [__] india
the the look at the therapy they're
doing in florida desantis is doing with
the [__] coat bag and the z pack and
all the guys
that's all he said that there's
alternative remedies than getting a
vaccine
that's it i don't know why people are
losing that [__] mind
and he proved it to you
that he had the alternative medicine
to get rid of it in five [__] days
you can't be mad at the guy
listen i feel a lot better now i feel a
lot more confident now and so should you
[__] now you know if you get
this [__] thing you're not gonna
[__] die
and rogan [__] proved it i think he
[__] did great by it so what he did
listen that's what america is we have
our own choice
if i said to you right now i'm going to
go do cocaine because cocaine
kills [__] covid what uh
it's like you ever think about the guy
who invented mushrooms
like who sat there one day
tipped over a cow
and said whoa there's a mushroom under
there
i'm gonna [__] eat this thing so
the guy who did the horse dewormer
you know he was looking at his horse
[__] he saw the worms climbing out of
it he's like maybe this will say [__]
covert i don't [__] know let me
[__] eat it i don't [__] know but
if he's cured in five days he didn't
have to go to the hospital
and he didn't die
that's success in my [__] world
if you're healthy and this is what we've
been discussing he was prepared for it
he was prepared for it
sleep
water vitamins sunlight
no stress
you know
he was prepared for it
he was prepared so when you're [__]
prepared
this is what happens
who the [__] is bothering me now
i have no [__] idea
everybody wants to know how kate is
doing i don't know how kate's doing it's
like i'm calling the [__] hospital
the hospital
i know what hospital she's at and i was
thinking about calling but they're not
gonna put you on the phone
unless your family and the hospital
can't tell you nothing because they'll
get [__] sued so
that's the problem we [__] have but
listen
i'm not here to [__] your [__] week
up i'm here to tell you that we learned
something
we learned now that uh
can't be doing [__] from the street no
more guys
it's over you got to know the people
you're copying this [__] from
if not
this is going to be the future now who
the [__] i think six people died in long
island last week from it
maybe it's the same maybe it's not i
don't [__] know
so it was
rico
fool
uh
somebody told me last night the dealer
died and his girlfriend passed so that's
four people that
you know two that were with kate
obviously or maybe three
i do not know i will keep you guys
posted
on wednesday's podcast as this uh opens
up you know
we're trying and i am going to help her
so for you guys that
checked up in on me this morning and on
patreon and on twitter and thank you
very much you know
uh i'm okay you know i'm feeling good i
i feel bad in my heart for her
i feel bad about how she must be feeling
right now you know this has to be
a little much for a little [__] head
you know uh
i'm not gonna put any pressure on her
like i said in a couple days we'll get a
hold of her and we'll explain to her
that we have a home here for her
i spoke to my wife about it and love and
a family and a child you know when
there's a child there's a little warmth
so i'll open up my door to her and maybe
uh
she stops doing this [__]
and maybe some of you guys will uh this
open up your eyes also like i said
the joint is not about [__] the most
thing it's not about [__] we're
better than you it's not about anything
it's just opening your eyes
to things that got me in [__] trouble
the last
40 years and trying to let you know that
don't stumble upon it and if you do get
in trouble
you're not [__] done
there is an answer and there is life
after that you just got to figure it out
on your own
[__] man up and move forward and keep
your [__] chin up and that's it
that's what i'm gonna tell kate to do
keep your chin up who gives a [__]
they're gonna talk bad about your
[__] anyway
who gives a [__] they get all [__]
suck your dick
and you have a job to do now you have to
prove to them that you're a bad
[__] the same way i did i got
locked up yeah i made some mistakes who
gives a [__] i'm a bad [__] now
it's time to [__] prove it nothing
wrong with making a [__] mistake like
i tell people all the time i'm not the
smartest [__] in the world you
know but i made 2 000 [__] more
mistakes than anybody else so i do know
a couple things about [__] mistakes
and i do know a little bit about getting
yourself out of a [__]
hole of misery and that's what we're
here for on the [__] joint so
uh write a little message for kate there
send joe rogan some love you
[__] tortured him on instagram
last week he got like 40 000 [__]
horrible messages
but it doesn't matter man as long as you
survive and what works for you
that's all that matters we've forgotten
this covert has [__] up our brain
this whole
thing has [__] us up completely i
don't know why we've gone away from our
humanity and we gotta go back to it
because
it's gonna be a long [__]
winter guys
if not so prepare for it
swallow your [__] pride a little bit
and man the [__] up like i said that's
it it's time to take [__]
responsibility you got the [__] world
by the balls it's monday it's labor day
we got a whole new [__] month
starting we got a whole new [__]
season starting we're going into the
winter we're going into covert [__]
cave over here in jersey i don't i hope
not i hope that
we blow pass through this i hope that we
don't
uh duplicate what happened in israel
which is what we look at the model we're
looking at what happens in israel and
great britain we expect it over here so
we're expecting a horrible [__]
winter but
i'm hoping for a good alternative i'm
sorry about my [__] gums they
cut into them again and they have to
replace the [__] uh bridge and the
bridge [__] fell off the other day so
if i'm talking a little weird i got to
wait till this afternoon to go back to
the [__] dentist and put the [__]
bridge in
and you guys want to know why i'm
[__] cracked but i'm good i'm having
a good [__] day it's going to be a
great week and it's going to be a great
month i made some [__] calls i think
i'm going to do the uh
the q a at uh
i forget what it is a festival they're
doing the 28th and 29th
i think i'm going to do eaton town the
movie theater in eatontown for the many
saints in newark
yeah we're still working on i'm trying
to get
i when i went down to amc yesterday i
spoke to them and they're like
well we don't know if we could do that
here we have to check with management so
[__] them
i'm gonna get a movie theater for
[__] kills me or an outdoor parking
lot a driving that will be the ticket
the driving would be a lot better if we
could just pull in with our [__] cars
and pull the [__] out of there when the
[__] movie's over that would be the
best bet i'd like to do it outside you
know so we could uh
nobody could get covered nobody you know
i don't have to feel [__] guilty
that's the thing i'm feeling most guilty
about but we're all [__] adults and
uh
you know we'll give a little space in
between chairs nobody have to smell each
other's farts i promise i don't like
smelling thoughts if you could smell a
fight you could smell covert you know
what i'm saying
nothing [__] changes i love you
[__] thank you happy labor day
that's it
the winter is [__] coming kids are
going back to school this weekend
i'm [__] ecstatic you understand me
but i'm more ecstatic about today's
podcast i think it was [__] great i
think we got the bases covered for a
[__] monday and i think you're on
you're ready to sling some [__] dick
and let them all sniff your [__] nut
sack all right
i love your [__] thank you for
supporting and now for a word from my
[__] sponsor jack
all right i want to thank you guys for
listening on a beautiful monday morning
happy labor day to you guys you know i
love you and i want you to have a great
week
the joint is brought to you by better
help what's standing in the way of
achieving your goals
nothing figure it out with better help
you know what's standing in the middle
you
listen i was having some problems i was
i had some doubts
and a friend of mine referred better
help and i got on board with dana and it
has been
tremendous we talked about the comedy
thing we talked about
my personal little couple little
problems i had
this is not a crisis line this is not
self-help better help is professional
therapy all online
it's all remote you won't have to lie on
a stupid couch ever again
you have a flexible schedule you could
do it on the phone
or on videos i do it on videos i do it
right on the computer you get a good
match they'll put you with a licensed
therapist who's right for you and if
they don't
you call them and they'll put you with
the right one
it's the most important part of therapy
you need someone you feel like you could
talk to who gets you and dana gets who i
am
it's fast when you sign up you can start
talking to your therapist within 48
hours
no waiting around it's affordable and
now you can send message to your
therapist anytime they'll get back to
you in between sessions
don't like your person if you want to
switch therapists you can do it anytime
for free
better help makes it nice and easy
they're 100 remote and available
worldwide you don't have to live in a
big city to get quality therapy anymore
trust me it helps to have somebody
outside your world to talk to i didn't
think so but boy did they change my mind
it's easy to schedule it's affordable
and they'll take a load off your
shoulders like it did me
over a million people have taken charge
of their mental health
especially now join them do me a favor
just for the joint listeners better help
has a great offer
i'm going to get you started you're
going to go to betterhelp.com
preston
diaz
okay so it's betterhelp.com
diaz i'm going to give you 10 off your
first month
that's better help h e l p
dot com slash diaz better b-e-t-t-e-r
come on i didn't even win
whatever
a spelling bee contest and i know
betterhelp.com
slash joey that's betterhelp.com
i'm going to give you 10 off your first
month
get better help today and start living
a happier life
the joint is also brought to you by
draftkings that's it
sunday
is the best
time of the [__] year you got the
[__] vikings at the bengals you got
the jets at the panthers you got the
seahawks at the colts
it's the first sunday of the nfl and
we're gonna win you some money on
draftkings
the joint is brought to you by
draftkings you could tell by my voice i
am [__] excited i love betting
football and this is my time of the year
draftking sportsbook is the official
sports betting partner of the nfl we're
gonna give all new players a hell of an
offer you ready
write this down you bet one dollar on
any football game in the nfl and you're
gonna cash 200 bucks and free bets let
me repeat that again because it's monday
you're a little [__] [__] from
the weekend
one dollar on any game and you're gonna
cash 200 bucks for free instantly no
matter what you heard me the [__] right
free
guidance but a dollar and get 200. are
you kidding me or what i know i got a
dollar and i could use 200 [__]
friends okay so draftkings is the best
in the west west it's safe
secure and reliable withdraw your money
at your
convenience that's very important so do
me a favor right now i know it's monday
you want to be prepared download the
draftking sportsbook app
use promo code joey when you sign up
receive 203 bets when you place a dollar
bet on any week one nfl game that's
promo code joey to get you 203 bets
instantly and that also works for
college ball i'm throwing that out there
too about any college game i'm going to
get you 200
in three bets for a limited time only at
draftkings sportsbook app the official
sports betting partner of the nfl you
got to be 21 older new jersey indiana
pennsylvania only restrictions apply see
draftkings.com
sportsbook for details now if you have a
gaming problem call 1-800 gambler if
you're in indiana call 1
809 with it if you're straight no
problems
download the draftking sportsbook app
and let's win some [__] getus it's
the first week the lines are going to be
soft i guarantee you make a little money
but it starts with you download the
draftking sportsbook app use promo code
joey to receive 200 and free bets
and hey
you got a winner here
download the draftking sportsbook app
and let's win some money the joint is
also brought to you by cbd lion
[__] phenomenal you understand me i
love these gummy bears right here
they're delicious
you take one of these [__] yellow
ones
and a little red one right here
and you blast them
oh my goodness
[__] delicioso
they stop the anxiety
they slow you down but hey it's all up
to you go to cbdline.com right now
read the third party lab results get to
learn about cbd
cbn and how it could help you
and let's get the ball going okay
health is the most important thing right
now
you're gonna be prepared you have to be
prepared
drinking water sleeping
cbd
let's get it all right it's that time of
the year go to cbdlion.com read
if you like something whether it's the
gummy bears the basketball
the hemp flower boom
press and co joey church joint and get
20 off delivered right to your house
cbd lion the best cbd out there how do i
know
it's been with me for three years it's
helped me through a surgery
and it's just phenomenal
you trust me you trust cbdlion.com right
now
pressing code joey i want to thank cbd
lion i want to thank better help and i
want to thank draftkings for giving you
free money
this sunday the nfl starts so you'll be
tip top magoo and [__] ready i love
you guys have a great monday have a
great labor day
we'll be back wednesday tip top magoo 7
a.m
to take you to a new [__] dimension i
love you [__] stay black
you